The general gonna experience.
The worst thing that could happen to a common cause he get real soft because
everybody loves you and they go to see you and they laugh at anything.
You say that's one of the reasons why Steve Martin said he stopped touring.
Right? Cause Steve Martin, when I was a kid, uh,
let's get small was out and he would come out with the bunny ears on and like
play the banjo. He was so good. These kids today,
these kids today, they don't know that Steve Martin was a monster.
No, they don't know about that, but they know they don't want hell rooms.
So we just shows up at the comedy.
I mean, they don't know how good Steve Martin was.
Like people forgot when Steve Barton was doing a re wasn't doing,
I dunno if it was.
No, he did. He did like the Nassau Coliseum. He got that big.
What he was doing, his albums,
like they were so silly and so fun and so differently.
He had his own unique style, you know? And, uh,
when he just felt like anything he did,
they laughed at and he lost track of whether or not it was good or not.
And he just stopped doing it.
And I remember thinking when I was first starting doing common,
I can't imagine a way that that could ever happen or B that you can't,
there's not a work around Steve. You're the.
Man. I think it really was.
He also had all these ideas for film and all this stuff that he did. Yeah. Um,
but you know, it's kind of interesting, like where he, where he,
what he used to say about, uh,
like I was such a serious time that he was coming out of all, like, you know,
the previous decade, all the assassinations, the Vietnam war,
the gas crisis and all that.
And all these comics were talking about all this heavy.
And he was just super silly. They just was like a mental break.
Um, somebody came to us, uh, with, uh, um, a pilot idea for something.
And it was over the top, like absurd and silly. And like, that was my reference.
I'm going through,
this is like the Steve Martin bunny here thing everybody's like going with Trump
and, and the virus and on and on. And it's like, this thing is just silly.
This knows no me to cancel called does nothing in here.
You can just sit down like that dumb and dumber type of thing.
That type of stuff that I love.
John tell you people, people today,
it's hard to appreciate how big he was. And I was a kid. Right. So that when,
when Steve Martin was huge, I mean, what year was it?
Late 74. But y'all, this is probably before that too. Yeah.
Was he still doing comic comedy in 84? I thought he,
I found a video that said it was a standard performance from 84.
Oh, that's probably right around the time when he stopped.
I thought he stopped before that.
But when I was in high school was when Steve Martin was born, standing up.
He's got a great book.
That's the book born, standing up,
you know what kills me is I loaned that to somebody, you know, gave it up.
I never got a baby.
Won. So he gave it up when I was a freshman in high school. The book is great.
Red band gave me the book for Christmas one year. It's really good. It's,
it's really interesting too, because like I said, I don't,
I think when you talk about like great comics of all these generations,
for whatever reason, people just think of him as a great movie star.
They think the jerk,
which is unbelievably funny movie and all those amazing movies that he did.
Was it like these kids.
So good. He was so sick. What was the mafia movie he played? What was that one?
When he.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. And he goes into the supermarket and he just,
he gets the price gun and everything's like 99 cents.
I'm just kinda standing there and he's scanning all this filet minions and
everything. What was that? Yeah. Yeah. Rick, Rick was man.
That was a great flux. The bit that you did on Saturday night live about Rick.
Miranda's getting punched in the face. I was.
Do you know? I thought that if anything, I thought, cause everybody loves Rick,
which I do too. Of course I was just, you know, was the postage.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.